MIKE?
>> Mike: PHIL KEATING LIVE
IN PARK LAND, FLORIDA AFTER
A HEART BREAKING WEEK THERE.
PHIL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GET SOME ANALYSIS NOW
FROM GEORGE WASHINGTON
UNIVERSITY LAW PROFESSOR
JONATHAN TURLEY.
GOOD EVENING, SIR.
>> THANKS, MIKE.
>> Mike: LET'S START WITH
THE INDICTMENTS.
WAS THAT A WARNING SHOT
FIRED BY THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
AT MOSCOW?
>> WELL, IT WAS QUITE A
SHOT.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS
WARNING OR BELOW THE WATER
LINE.
BETWEEN THE LINES, IT'S
CLEARLY SAYING THIS WAS A
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
OPERATION.
IT IS SPONTANEOUSLY HAPPEN
THAT YOU HAVE DOZENS OF
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN A HACKING
OPERATION WITH ELABORATE
DISGUISINGS OF THEIR GROUPS,
THEIR IDENTIFIED AT THIS.
IT IS SUGGESTING THAT I
THINK THIS IS A GOVERNMENT
OPERATION.
NOW, THAT POINTS TO VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT
IT DOESN'T REALLY POINT TO
DONALD TRUMP.
DESPITE THE DOZENS OF PAGES,
THERE IS ONE WORD THAT IS
LIKELY TO BE CITED IN THIS
WHOLE STORY.
AND THAT IS UNWITTING.
THE ADJECTIVE UNWITTING
APPEARS IN THE INDICTMENT TO
DESCRIBE TRUMP OFFICIALS WHO
HAD CONTACT WITH THESE
RUSSIANS.
THEY SAY THEY DIDN'T KNOW
THEY WERE RUSSIANS.
BUT WHAT'S FASCINATING IS IT
DOESN'T SUGGEST THAT THEY
HAVE EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
AND THIS WAS BROUGHT OUT BY
ROFN STEIN.
>> Mike: ACTUALLY, WE HAVE
THAT SOUND BITE.
LET'S GO TO IT IF WE CAN.
>> THERE IS NO ALLEGATION IN
THIS INDICTMENT THAT ANY
AMERICAN WAS A KNOWING
PARTICIPANT IN THIS ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY.
THERE IS NO ALLEGATION IN
THE INDICTMENT THAT THE
CHARGED CONDUCT ALTERED THE
OUTCOME OF THE 2016
ELECTION.
>> Mike: SO YOUR ANALYSIS OF
THAT POINT?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHAT'S
FASCINATING.
IT'S BEEN A YEAR WITH
MULTIPLE PLEA AGREEMENTS.
A LOT OF TESTIMONY.
A LOT OF INTERVIEWS.
AND THEY ARE SAYING THAT
THEY STILL DON'T HAVE ANY
EVIDENCE OF ANY KNOWING
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE RUSSIANS
INVOLVED IN THIS EFFORT.
THAT HAS TO BE GOOD NEWS TO
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
IT'S ALSO NOTABLE THAT
MEETING IN TRUMP TOWERS ARE
MENTIONED.
THEY KNEW THOSE WERE
RUSSIANS.
BUT IF THEY WERE PART OF
THIS EFFORT, THERE WOULD BE
SOME REFERENCE.
THERE THEIR IDENTITY WAS
CLEAR.
ALSO THAT IS NOT MENTIONED.
>> Mike: IS SOME OF THIS
BASICALLY SAYING TO THE
FOLKS BEHIND US ON CAPITOL
HILL AND AROUND THE COUNTRY
THAT WANT SOME ANSWERS ABOUT
THIS AND WANT SOME ACTION
TAKEN ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO
OUR ELECTION IN 2016 THAT
SERIOUS PEOPLE ARE ON THE
CASE AND TAKING STEPS TO
ADDRESS THIS?
>> I THINK IT DOES.
TRUTH COMES OUT OF THIS.
EVERYONE THROWING AROUND AND
CONSPIRACIES.
2014.
BEGAN BEFORE THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THE RUSSIANS WERE TAKING
TARGETS OF OPPORTUNITY.
THEY WERE SHOOTING AT
EVERYBODY NUT ELECTIONS.
CERTAINLY WORKING MORE
AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON.
BUT WHAT IT DOES SHOW IS
THAT THEY DID A REALLY QUITE
IMPRESSIVE JOB IN FINDING
THE CYBER TRAIL TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
>> Mike: RIGHT.
>> THIS IS NOT OVER.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE GOING TO HAVE SERIOUS
PROBLEMS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
BEEN TAGGED.
>> Mike: LET'S SWITCH GEARS
TO THE DEVASTATING STORY,
PARK LAND, FLORIDA, THE FBI
SAYS IT GOT A WARNING,
DROPPED THE BALL.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T AGREE
WITH GOVERNOR SCOTT THAT
DIRECTOR WRAY SHOULD RESIGN.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S IN
ANY WAY RESPONSIVE.
THERE IS NO INDICATION THAT
HE HAD A DIRECT INVOLVEMENT
IN THIS.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO FIND OUT
THE TRUTH TO THIS.
IT IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
YOU CAN'T TELL PEOPLE SEE
SOMETHING, SAY SOMETHING IF
THE NEXT LINE IS DO NOTHING.
YOU KNOW, IT REALLY
UNDERMINES WHAT THE FBI HAS
BEEN WORKING FOR YEARS TO
TRY TO GET PEOPLE TO DO.
SO, THERE HAS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY HERE AND
EXPLANATION.
WHEN YOU READ THE LEVEL OF
DETAIL THAT WAS GIVEN TO THE
FBI, IT'S BREATHTAKING THAT
ANYONE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THAT PHONE WOULDN'T GO OH MY
GOD AND IMMEDIATELY START TO
RALLY PEOPLE TO GET ON THIS.
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT WENT INTO
A DRAWER AND LEFT THERE.
>> Mike: HERE IS AN
EXPLANATION FROM THE FBI.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THE CALLER PROVIDED
INFORMATION ABOUT NIKOLAS
CRUZ, THE POTENTIAL OF HIM
BECOMING A SCHOOL SHOOTER.
UNDER NORMAL PROTOCOL.
THIS INFORMATION SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED TO THE MIAMI
FIELD OFFICE.
THEIR INVESTIGATIVE STEPS
WOULD HAVE BEEN TAKEN.
THE FBI HAD DETERMINED THAT
PROTOCOL WAS NOT FOLLOWED.
>> Mike: YOU HAVE BEEN
AROUND THIS TOWN A LONG
TIME.
SHOULD SOMEBODY GO FOR THIS?
>> QUITE FRANKLY I THINK
SOMEBODY SHOULD BE FIRED FOR
THIS IF NOT WRAY WE HAVE TO
FIND OUT WHO WAS
RESPONSIBLE.
THE FBI HAS BEEN ACCUSE YOU
HAD NOT SHARING INFORMATION
IN THE PAST WITH LOCAL
AUTHORITIES.
THAT'S A BIG GRIPE THAT YOU
HEAR FROM A LOT OF
PROSECUTORS, INVESTIGATORS.
THIS ONE IS FAR, FAR MORE
SERIOUS.
NOBODY RECEIVING THAT
INFORMATION COULD JUST VIEW
THIS AS ONE MORE CALL ABOUT
SOME, YOU KNOW, SOME KID
SAYING STUPID THINGS.
THIS WAS DETAILED AND THIS
WAS ELM INCIDENT